us here now louisiana senator john
kennedy senator you actually had an
interesting line and you said the biden
administration as it relates to the
border they lie like they breathe about
illegal immigration i'll let you um
explain that to us
sean i can't think of a single
presidential administration
that has broken more plates
in its first nine months
than the biden administration i mean
think about it
you were talking about it earlier
afghanistan
inflation
crime
critical race theory
gas prices
the destruction of america's energy
independence
and and yet uh of all of the president
screw-ups
there's not a single one
greater than the crisis at the board and
it is a crisis this year over 2 million
people will come into this country
illegally and we don't have the
slightest idea
who they are
now i think it's worth asking why
and to me there are only one or two
possible explanations
the first is incompetence
it may be that the president has put in
charge of his immigration policy
um a bunch of pink-haired wokers
who don't know their uh their ass from
their elbow
um
i use ass in the king james
bible sense
it may be that the president's put in
charge of his immigration policy people
who shouldn't be allowed to think for
themselves because it's too dangerous
it may be
that the president has put in charge of
his immigration policy
people who are um
are bilingual they speak english speak
english and stupid
now the second part the second
possibility is that this is all
intentional
um that the president believes in an
open border policy
and uh you have to watch what people do
not what they say and that he doesn't
want to say it to the american people
because he knows
that that'll be about as popular with
the american people as a as a uh
so another things
in other words would this senator be oh
here's the greatest thing we can give as
a gift
american citizenship we know they're
trying to force amnesty in the
reconciliation bill
uh in the hopes that they'll vote for
democrats we're going to give you the
greatest gift we can give you free
citizenship we're going to sneak it
under the radar and not even have a vote
on it is that a possible motivation
sure we we just don't know but we do
know one thing
there's a solution
and it's very simple
all the president has to do
is go back to what we were doing in
december
the month before he took office
i'm talking about the remaining mexico
program the safe third country
agreements the border wall and
deportation it'll work it work then
it'll work now all he's got to do is go
back and do it
you know senator you speak from a place
of good old common sense we did that
we'd solve the problem but why would we
ever want to do that
unbelievable and we wouldn't abandon
americans behind enemy lines i think
i'll take mean tweets and a tough
american president over this disaster
thank you sir for being with us hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else